[Music]
alright guys I have an advice column in
front of me so I will read it
it begins with dear Karen feeding my son
is 17 he's been in a relationship with a
girl for the past year she's been
through a lot
dealing with a severe medical diagnosis
and several surgeries our characterize
her as an anxious person generally even
before those things happened and they
have both felt a lot of stress during
that time thankfully she's now much
better and things seem to have
normalized what concerns me is the
changes I have seen in my formerly
confident and outgoing son over the last
year he has become anxious and
frequently very down on himself
despite being a pretty accomplished and
articulate kid he has applied to a
challenging university program but says
he now doesn't feel ready his girlfriend
has decided not to go off to school next
year due to her health concerns and I
know at least in part he wants to wait
for her we have talked about making
decisions about his future based on his
own needs but this relationship seems to
have become really influential he has
made several decisions about next year
without even talking to us about it he
started seeing a therapist and has
become more open with us recently but
but I'm just concerned about handling
the situation carefully I'd like to see
him go on to this program that he'd been
interested in which requires an audition
but I don't want to push him if he's
actually not ready what to do signed
worried it's the girlfriend hmm
what do you guys think they ain't one I
don't think you should be afraid of like
going to Phoenix Phoenix University
finishes diversity
online classes oh yeah that's not really
that challenging
yeah the support of your family there so
I think that's something he should just
go ahead and embrace well I guess this
advice would be for the mom how does she
go about let go sometimes man come on
dude your kids dating and he's going to
college and [ __ ] what you can't attach
that hard let him figure it out that the
kid is getting wrecked by his love life
choices of course no but that's gonna
happen those are things that are gonna
happen and you have to like kind of
stumble and fall on your face and then
to realize your mistakes and then fix it
the mom can never compete with vagina
never understand never well I mean I
think they do sometimes yes that's the
thing like she's like I feel like I'm
losing my son all of this is like yes
you love them - l'chaim
you seen the back she's better than like
drugs no but I heard about this season
of Bachelor the mom Barbie oh yeah why
is she even there was she involved has a
mom ever been involved in bet he lives
with his mom oh and she knows all the
details of his sex life yeah
Wow like she seems me The Bachelor she's
my cat he's a mama's boy yeah yeah he
just [ __ ] his mom maybe yes but now the
point is that Nicki's making is that the
the barb though the woman was too
interested in what he was doing and she
like full-on shaky cried at him like
please marry this one girl and not to
suffer you much like gave him an
ultimatum like you're making the wrong
choice and she like did this whole
dramatic like crying thing and it was
like you played it in every single
trailer there's such good TV these
destroyed ass [ __ ] TV yeah bad TV
that's so funny but cuz it's so fun to
hate on people then are fun to hate on
right yeah because what I don't like is
hating on real people right like people
I know my friends like family on stuff
but getting to focus it all on one place
like shitty me out of TV that's what
it's designed for
there's dudes that want to [ __ ] their
mom but cats would have to [ __ ] another
chick and the mom gets a tongue blew the
[ __ ] see that's the best there's a show
for that I will get too hyped up in the
reality TV our first time ever like we'd
never watched any of those rooms we're
watching love island like love island
love is blind and bachelor all back
binging right quarantine before the
quarantine quarantine is celery flavor
of love and I literally saw the tweet
yesterday I was like Coral Cove II
started with 2006 with a pumpkin spin on
New York face and I remember thinking
this is reality TV history right now
there's only show I gave a [ __ ] about
reality TV that was the only one I saw
both seasons you like that so did his
war record for wig snatching yeah I was
the object and the only like I saw from
that the only thing I ever watched the
side of that was American Idol the first
season we play in uh you know it's Kelly
Park Kelly Clarkson that's my go-to
karaoke song - which one that's since
you've been gone
wait that wasn't what you did since
you've been gone do you even know
[ __ ] Kelly Clarkson are you kidding
me bro this is white history no first of
all my introduction to calc orchids
Clarke sake American Idol and then I
went on just just to say that her single
since you've been gone is one of my
favorite on here a couple bars yeah okay
here we go here's the thing we started
our friends here for it was cool but it
was
operative and you
[Laughter]
my shirt is off never seen a black guy
love Kelly Clarkson as much as I do know
this about you I think you can say
cracker now no you're fine you're fine
you're fine I'm in there like booty hair
yeah you're 23 Dean was a lot of
Europeans okay technically that's a
great gym it's a great gym no she knew
we should just do like a karaoke
facetime or the high what do you which
one you doing the most on a stick I
think I think it's RAM you could do like
it the most group where you can like
have shared so is going live with
so-and-so oh that would be cool to go to
the door like that but I was someone
like a group that's some cold [ __ ] yeah
that's gonna be dope I like that okay
the log is done okay well as you guys
may recall this was about an advice
column and then are you guys interested
at all it's to see the response
absolutely yeah yeah people gave
responses because they're writing into
an advice column and then they responded
to an advice column I thought you said I
have a device column I'll say well what
technologies help you sorry Nolan I
thought you'll [ __ ] this [ __ ] well it's
the technology
okay so G right I'm probably gonna get
eviscerated in the comments for this but
I'm inclined to say that it's not the
worst thing in the world for your son to
delay College parenthesis or enter a
less challenging program of study for a
spell because he wants to wait for his
sick girlfriend maybe it's the steady
stream of horrible news we're
experiencing right now but I think the
human connections that we have in the
present can be significant if not more
as the dreams of professional success we
may have for the future also even if
this is a little more than puppy love
and will fade away sooner than later it
still seems that the events of the past
year have taken quite a toll on your son
and understandably so watching a peer go
through significant health challenges
can be a painful reminder of the
fragility of one's own body watching a
loved one suffer such issues while being
unable to protect her from them is one
of the most devastating experiences a
person can have and he's had it at a
very young age as as such his readiness
for this program and the application
process may have taken a blow it may be
demoralizing for him to attempt at this
audition and not secure admission
because his focus wasn't there or
because he hadn't had adequate time to
prepare it's great that he's in therapy
and becoming more communicative
encourage him to stay on this path and
work with him parentheses and perhaps a
school guidance counselor or instructor
to develop a plan to continue pursuing
whatever it is he was working toward I'm
assuming something artistic while
honoring his need to have more time at
or near home let him know that you are
willing to continue to be supportive and
respectful of his relationship but that
he must plan for a future that isn't
entirely centered around it either
hoping for good health and wise moves
for all involved
Jeff was really will we yeah why is this
so well written like that I can't hate
on it too I'm not a huge component for a
promoter of college now at one point I
definitely was I feel like my college
career was amazing but it really it
wasn't really the knowledge aspect it
was more of the network that I got from
college
that's that I think that's you're there
to get it skill like lawyer doctor or
something like that yeah you always hate
on it from that angle yeah everyone
always like JK's against colleges like
no we're talking about you have to know
what you want to do if college is a step
towards your profession then 100 percent
it's a good investment but if it's not
if you're just going there because
everyone else is the college experience
you're gonna be stuck in student loan
debt forever and not only that that's
why it's really not that big of a deal
where he does maybe like the first two
years because that's just general
studies so you're just gonna be taking
like math English oh yeah sure right all
of that like so that you do that a
community college and longest credits
transfer over then you literally
probably just saved yourself 20 30
thousand dollars by doing it that way
and transfer as long as everything is
transferable but agreed like unless it's
one of the you know the doctor laureate
things that you really need to go to
school for a lot of [ __ ] I said this on
my podcast months ago actually last year
I was like yo with all the videos on
YouTube you too should open a university
and they should like just get accredited
people to teach classes and and sense
like do this online and literally a
couple weeks ago I saw a [ __ ] banner
for like YouTube University they do not
a bunch of like master classes yeah like
let's crazy and like I really think that
especially now what's up you start to
help do stuff no that's nothing that I
don't think you started it yeah
absolutely idea but the thing now
especially with so many people so many
universities all being online now
because of this cause it I think that a
lot of people are going to try to take
advantage of this and then also this may
shift people from going to the
traditional setting of college to doing
more online stuff so I think that it'll
be fun yeah your college experience now
is like in a dorm room with a [ __ ]
laptop on me tick tock where I was like
it was like diff types of people that go
to this school it was like if you got
into Harvard it's probably probably one
those people that's really smart but now
you go to online school if you got into
Yale you're probably on those people
that practice about your grades and
wants to be a doctor but now you go to
online school
they're like it got down to Phoenix
online I was like you probably want
those few lists like haha I was already
taking online school but guess what
you're also now in online school
yeah that's good man
[Music]